all right so welcome everyone to this
session
my name is Elia Brodsky I'm CEO of pine
biotech one of the co-founders and I
want to briefly tell you about
um bioinformatics in general I'm sure
that you all have different backgrounds
um so I'm really ready to learn more
about your background and your interests
as well and hopefully we will be able to
do that throughout the meeting together
um I would love to you know know where
you're from which country what is your
interest
what degree maybe you have
um at your University
and where are you headed why did you
decide to join this particular webinar
or this program in general so as we go
through the next few minutes uh we'll
start looking at how we can make sense
of it all and kind of find a right place
for bioinformatics and data science and
understand what opportunities uh lay
ahead for these disciplines if we are
interested in biology biotechnology Etc
so what is my background uh my
background when I was
um you know
um a young adult I uh was in a in an
Applied Mathematics
um and the reason I went into Applied
Mathematics originally was because of my
parents uh my father is a mathematician
a statistician and he thought that this
was the right way to go and so I decided
to join that program unfortunately uh
very quickly I realized that that is not
exactly what I want to do with my life
and I quit that program
uh fast forward you know 10 15 years
later
um I realized that actually everywhere
you go whatever field you are in uh data
and understanding of how to manage and
analyze this data is critical and so uh
today I have over eight years of
experience already with bioinformatics
and have been a part of many projects
that are very interesting but would not
be successful if they did not have a
data analysis and a data management
component
so I'll briefly talk about those later
throughout this session uh but before we
jump into that I want to kind of give
you a little overview of what I hope to
cover in today's session so
first I'll talk about the role of data
in the research life cycle how it is
important to know what kind of data is
going to be generated and it is
important to know how to then analyze
and interpret this data in the context
of an experiment
I also want to talk about the role of
the person who does that and in the
context of you know whether you are
exclusively focused on just data
analysis or you are actually focused on
combining different skills of
biology and research and bioinformatics
or data science
and then I'll talk about how to get
started so what I find with a lot of
people that get into bioinformatics for
the first time
they are being told in a very
traditional way to get started with very
simple things and on one hand it is the
right way to do it because you need to
learn the basics before you move into
more advanced things but on the other
hand it is also intimidating for people
who have a lot of experience who are you
know very smart who are passionate about
what they do because it's irrelevant
right and so there's a fear of losing
time of doing something irrelevant of
not really understanding how what I am
learning fits in with what I really want
to do
then I want to talk to you about your
future career you might be thinking of
your academic career or you might want
to go into industry
and so we'll talk a little bit about
what are people looking for right what
are those skills what are those uh types
of experiences that potential employers
might be interested in and how can you
leverage what you do with Onyx logic uh
in those discussions in those plans
and that brings us to uh kind of the
availability of many different resources
online that you could potentially go
into that have you know excellent
lectures different kinds of coding
exercises and tutorials so really talk a
little bit about you know how to
organize those kinds of things in a way
that it can actually help you build up
your background your portfolio and what
does that mean how does that practically
work
and then finally we'll talk a little bit
about our community because this is more
than just a discussion about training or
acquiring skills or even developing a
research project uh really we are here
today because there is a global
community of people who come from
different backgrounds that are
interested in life sciences but also
data and to build up this community to
participate in this community you need
to be able to give and take at the same
time so hopefully we'll talk a little
bit about how you can contribute and how
you can benefit as well
so let me start with uh kind of talking
a little bit about
molecular biology in the context of
precision medicine
um recent Innovation with biotechnology
and biomedical research has led to these
high throughput Technologies right and
these high throughput Technologies allow
us to understand what is happening at
the under at the subcellular level but
it is reliant on a parallel development
of computational Technologies and those
computational Technologies are
potentially useful if they could be
applied to solve these data analysis
gaps and really this gap between data
and information even though more and
more people acquire data science skills
continues to grow
now that leads us to the question why
why even though we have all of these
Technologies right in the lab we have
these Technologies in the computational
world why does this Gap continue to grow
and the reason why it continues to grow
is because these Technologies in the
hands of experts allow them to generate
data quickly
in an automated way right what what does
it mean in an automated way that means
that you go home and the Machine
continues to generate new data right so
when you look at it that way uh it
really means that you know there's a
handful of experts that are able to now
analyze this data and the rest of the
people are waiting for those experts and
that creates a bottleneck and that
bottleneck leads to an ever-growing gap
between the amount of data that is
available and the information that we
extract from this data
in a recent survey
um they asked researchers what kinds of
steps they are more or less familiar
with in the context of Next Generation
sequencing and it turns out that the
majority of the people more than 50
percent uh today that was a while back
now but today more than 50 percent are
intimidated by the data analysis part
because really data analysis is a
process it's a process that includes
exploratory analysis that expl it
includes kind of thinking of the
specific contrasts and comparisons that
we can make so a lot of people are
actually intimidated by this process of
not being able to analyze data
effectively and so what we've seen as
the real challenge here is the challenge
of
bioinformatics in general
it's an incredibly Dynamic field with a
lot of changes
um You probably all know
um you know Illumina was uh at some
point was not even around right and so
everybody relied on Sanger sequencing
and microarrays then illuminae came
along and everybody jumped on aluminum
today Oxford nanopore is kind of the
emerging technology with a little bit of
a different technique to generate data
right so this technology continues to
evolve in a fairly rapid way there's
always new packages new scripts new ways
to visualize data and so you have to be
understanding of how all of that ties
together
the universities where a lot of This
research happens they have a limited
amount of computational resources that
are available to everyone to use and to
store that data and also students even
though they understand then
theoretically what needs to be done it's
a time consuming and very complicated
process so you really need experience
and then finally I think that um you
know we look at faculty who are supposed
to be teaching students how to do this
but they really have limited experience
themselves and there's just not enough
talent
for teaching effectively these skills
and so to address these challenges what
our team has done
is we have started building out the
omics logic portal and the Onyx logic
portal is designed to standardize
organize and systematize this
information available on bioinformatics
training so this challenge is recognized
by many around the world we're not the
only ones who recognize the challenge
but we believe that this portal that we
have put together with the different
resources and I'll talk about what those
resources are really helps address some
of that challenge
so we talked about the role of data we
talked about you know how to
um kind of see this right and and now
let's talk a little bit about the
psychology of getting started overcoming
the fear of solving irrelevant problems
um so to do this uh we'll do a little
bit of a
um a practical thing uh so first of all
I believe all of you
should already have a profile on the
Onyx logic portal right
uh the onions logic portal uh let me
just quickly kind of walk you through I
know that many of you are probably
already familiar with it but I'll just
walk you through a couple of things
right here on the home page so uh this
portal is designed to introduce several
important kind of components that I
think are very useful if you're you know
interested in getting into this field of
bioinformatics number one we have Mentor
guided programs so these are experts who
have a lot of practical experience in
bioinformatics already and they conduct
training programs throughout the year
uh we have practical assignments where
you can understand the logic of the
analysis maybe not being well versed in
the technical aspects of bioinformatics
uh there's coding exercises and those
coding exercises
are um kind of available on demand which
means that if you need it you can learn
how to do it but if you don't need it
you don't need to worry about it and
then what's important is also it allows
us to kind of understand for you
yourself right to quantify your progress
so what what I wanted you to do right
now is to go into your profile so by the
way let me ask you how many of you have
already created a profile on onyxlogic
if you have please share the link to
your profile in the chat box so the way
you can do it is uh you can go to your
profile by clicking on your email
address here on top
okay and copy this link above and share
it
so this is my profile for example uh
okay so let me know if you have
completed your profile I'll give it a
couple of minutes so you all can share
and hopefully we will learn a little bit
about
um each other through this process as
well
all right thank you
so this profile
and you know if you are able to please
share the link to your profile as well
this will help us um connect with you
and you know will also help us all kind
of learn about each other uh this
profile is what people see right when
they
um
when they find you right so for example
if I'm an employer right and I'm looking
for my own from additions because
there's a lack of qualified
bioinformations and someone comes to me
I would like to know what has this
person done or learned right
um if I'm a potential collaborator right
I'm a research
um I have a research lab I need to find
someone to collaborate with
it's a way to show what you know how to
do right so what's on this page first of
all it's always nice to see who you are
right
so uh I uploaded my picture here
um and this is actually what I looked
like a few years ago
um there's social media and the social
media is an important part of our
day-to-day life and I recommend for
everyone to have a social media profile
in the research world if you are
publishing and it's also useful to have
a
um a way to share what your Publications
are and Orchid is a good place where you
can list out those Publications that you
have been a part of uh but an important
Community I think professionally is
LinkedIn
so I have my LinkedIn profile here as
well and by the way I recommend all of
you uh I I recommend that we connect so
if you do have your LinkedIn profile
you're welcome to connect with me and
I'll also show you
um our community here on LinkedIn where
we have a community of over 2 000
members from all over the world where
you know they specialize in machine
learning in biomedical research and it's
a really great place to find out about
job opportunities about you know
research projects that people are
working on
Etc so please join this community on
LinkedIn as well
so what else do we have here an
important part here is a little blurb a
bio about you okay and by the way we
have our team here with us
um on this uh on the zoom meeting and
they are taking notes of all of your
profiles and and hopefully we will be
able to review them so the first thing
that you want to do is you want to
present yourself in a good way and the
way to do that is you click on edit your
profile
so when you edit your profile you can
add your name or change it a good way to
change your name is to make sure that
you have capital letters in the
beginning and not all capital letters
right this is important because when you
get to certification that shows
professionalism the first thing that
people might be looking at you can add
here the links to your social media and
please use the full link with https and
and the full link of this uh present as
well
um and after you are done your profile
is going to say that it is a hundred
percent complete okay so if you have not
done this yet
please do that today so that we can
continue and stay in touch after this
session because I really believe in in a
growing community that can learn from
each other and and this is an important
part of what we're trying to do here at
omix logic the second thing is you will
find here under the course tab all of
the courses and projects that you have
taken or are in the process of
completing so you can see that for some
projects I have done just a little bit
um some of them I maybe have done more
and as you want to turn to a course that
you have completed you will also see
that there's a certificate and this
certificate is something that you can
share for example on social media right
so here I've completed introduction to
bioinformatics and I can see a
certificate and share it with the
community telling everyone that now I am
learning how to do that
okay so let's go back now I hope that
all of you took a little bit of time to
complete your profile
um and by the way if you want to see if
uh what activity
um is there you can go to the
achievements tab right here
and you will be able to see that some
people are actually completing their
profile right now right so after you
complete your profile you are given 500
points and so you're moving ahead you're
moving along you're maybe over to taking
some people you might be becoming more
proficient than others and and it's
something that we can measure
okay so here you can see
um excellent other people that have uh
joined and I love the fact that somebody
completed their profile so I'm going to
like it right here
um let's go back to our presentation so
how to get started overcoming the fear
of solving irrelevant problems let's
talk a little bit about the process of
learning so the process of learning is
not something that just happens by
itself in fact there's a lot of research
going on into the process of learning
and how you become proficient at
something and I hope that all of you
have thought about this as well and I
definitely have because when you are
starting with something new and
bioinformatics might be a new topic for
many of us here
that topic is you know when you speak to
an expert in that topic it's almost like
speaking a different language right it's
almost like you are you know speaking
Chinese all of a sudden because every
single word you need to understand what
does it mean so the process of learning
starts with acquiring that language and
that uh you know lexicon of that domain
kind of understanding the basic concepts
understanding the facts uh knowing what
ideas or concepts are being used and as
you build up right so if we think about
it as a pyramid if you kind of start
building up on that Foundation
eventually you are able to use that
information in a practical way you can
apply it and when you read a publication
you can start drawing connections
between different ideas and then you can
start thinking critically about someone
saying I did this like this or I did it
like that right so you are starting to
really grow in your understanding and
eventually at some point right here you
can start creating new or original work
so thinking about this process of going
from kind of understanding the basics
building on that to apply that
information in a guided way and
eventually becoming more and more
independent and practical we have
started thinking about that process and
thinking about how can we make Onyx
logic built around this process and so
this is what we did right we created a
portal that brings together resources
that are of different levels they have
practical things they have conceptual
things and they also have a mentor
guided more kind of open-ended and
creative aspects as well and that's
really the message of today's meeting
and you know hopefully this is something
that you can take away from today's
session is a better understanding of how
this resource can be helpful to you and
what else you can do with it besides
just you know joining a few sessions and
looking at a few online courses which is
of course what you can find on many
other places as well
so let's talk about how to you know do
this in a way that you can actually gain
something out of it so we said the first
place is to say I'm a part of this
community create your profile and
complete it right upload your picture
give us a bio what are you interested in
what are you doing what is your
background what is your educational
level
and then connect us to your life to
social media right to your Professional
Profile to your academic profile Etc and
then you want to start somewhere right
so where do you start if you go to the
courses tab right here
you will find over here several
different ways to navigate the different
resources that we have these are tags
right here and these are Collections and
you will find here a collection called
getting started
so I recommend for everyone to
start right here
and the first course that I hope most of
you have already completed is this
course called introduction to
bioinformatics so introduction to
bioinformatics is a course that is
designed to give you this high level
overview of bioinformatics as a
discipline and the way it is used in
different domains domains like
Healthcare biotechnology and agriculture
really it's surprising to know that
bioinformatics as a discipline has
evolved tremendously and now is being
used in a variety of different ways
across all of these domains or
Industries so this will give you a brief
introduction with a little bit of
history of how did we get here so this
is a place to get started right this is
a place where anyone can maybe complete
this course and maybe an hour or two or
three right so it's a really short
course
the second one that I would start with
is bytes and molecules now bites and
molecules is a more expanded course and
here's why
it starts off by speaking about just
this idea that bytes or data and
molecules or biology are becoming more
and more
interconnected and the reason for that
is that we can study biology by using
data and as we study it more and more we
understand the potential that this
approach to studying biology has as an
impact on many different applications
the second course talks about citizen
science right and what is citizen
science citizen science is that everyone
can participate in meaningful scientific
discovery it's not only a domain for
professors who sit in you know labs and
and do research because data is so
widely accessible because experts that
sit in Labs all day long at top
universities like Stanford or MIT are
generating this data and making it
publicly accessible all of us members of
the public can access that data and make
new discoveries make new and interesting
discoveries so that's an important
component here that we whether we are in
research or just starting to get
interested everyone can be involved and
then from there it starts building on
these important Concepts that you need
to know to be able to analyze data you
need to understand the terminology you
need to understand where the data is
generated and then you need to
understand what to do with it and then
we have a few introductory courses into
genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics and these are the types of
omics data
that you can leverage in your project so
these two courses by the way you can see
that all of these courses are free right
so if you anyone right you join this
portal and anyone can start learning
about all of these for absolutely free
so hopefully by the time that you are
done with this uh this program or this
uh you know series of webinars you have
completed at least two free courses
introduction to bioinformatics and buy
some molecules and this will already
give you a lot as you can see we have
introduction to different omics data and
then applications and you can even get
started learning about uh programming
languages and also get introduced to the
T battle info platform a platform where
you can actually see how big data is
logically analyzed
and how to get some meaningful outputs
okay so how many of you have already
started with introduction to
bioinformatics
and uh and the bytes and molecules
so if you have started uh or completed
uh you can write you know something like
completed
introduction
and started
tomorrow
[Music]
okay perfect many of us um completed
introduction to my informatics
okay great we have about 70 or two
participants who have shared their
success with us
okay excellent
okay so great so if you're already
completing or have completed
introduction to bioinformatics you know
exactly what I'm talking about and then
excellent tomorrow we will have a
webinar on biotin molecules
thank you everyone
excellent yeah so if you have completed
introduction to bioinformatics again
what can you do with that so you want to
go to your profile go under certificates
and find that certificate introduction
to bioinformatics right here
you can view that certificate
okay this certificate is something that
you want to share
you see this is my certificate I can
share it
so how do I share it I download it
I go right here
and I share it with the community
okay sorry the way to do this is to save
it first as an image
I'm going to make an image real quick
and now I can share it
okay
I can say
um
something like this okay so once I have
this I can also tag other people for
example I think that a lot of people on
our team have contributed to developing
this course and I'm going to tag some of
those people right here
like sonalika or Jesse
and
Mohit
but because I'm here with you I will
also
um add a tag to
Mr adekunle and
Daniel
um
maybe he's not here
I am Fair
okay so now that I have shared this
people in this group are going to know
about my progress right and so now you
can see that I have completed this
um and and I um can move on to next
exciting challenges like the bytes and
molecules okay and I'm sure that the
recorded uh version will be shared with
you as well
so getting started right after we get
started what do we do next
so getting started will be introduction
to bioinformatics bytes and molecules
getting started with bioinformatics in R
A programming language that is very
useful in many aspects of bioinformatics
and getting started with bioinformatics
in Python so let me briefly uh then tell
you about what else you are going to be
able to do after you have completed
these basic introductory modules so the
basic idea of this portal is to collect
information
that is
um kind of the foundation for uh
becoming proficient and understanding
the logic of bioinformatics in whatever
project you end up going with
and we've organized it around the types
of data so you will see here genomics
transcript atomics metagenomics and
skills so for example data science is a
more coded code oriented direction or in
some cases we can look at it as a more
logic oriented right so not necessarily
becoming an engineer and learning how to
code everything on your own but still
understanding the logic of the analysis
so that you can also use this analysis
in an effective way
so really we have two paths One path is
no code where you understand the logic
of the analysis and the second path is
code oriented so that you know how to
start coding some of those logical steps
and turning those steps into a project
right and that's the third component
where we have essentially mentors and
Mentor guided programs that allow you to
develop an independent research project
so how can you learn bioinformatics
without any coding
the way to do this is to get started
with the t-bion for platform where you
can process many different types of data
that are found on the public domain and
extract meaningful information so that
you can start playing with that data and
understand what it does so for example
here we have one optional result from
such a data analysis project and this is
a result for single cell sequencing so
something that is being used a lot today
in research
uh let's take a look at at how this
works how this looks um in real life now
all of you that have signed up are
actually
um you have access to the t-bound for
platform so to get there uh this is the
link
let me share that with you in chat
okay please take a moment to get to this
link
um and try to log in the way to log in
right here you can see I'm logged in but
if I was to log out
I would click on login
and here I would use my email
address
to get in
okay so let me know once you're in and
we'll do a little uh practical thing
together to see how this works
all right let me know once you're here
anyone
okay did anyone uh arrive at this link
all right great thank you no no anyone
else
all right perfect
okay so once you are here
let's take a look at a simple pipeline
okay it's going to be very simple at
first but again in the coursework and in
your future sessions you will learn
about more um things like this so yeah
there's no steps right now we're just
going to this link
um so if you're here great yeah so if
you're on this page again you need to be
logged in
if you have logged in you how do you
know that you're logged in you hover
over this and you see your email address
right so if you see your email address
that means you are locked in
so what we'll do is we'll go to this
simple Pipeline and we'll go to
differential expression section right
here and we'll click on this down down
arrow button
and then we'll go into this Alzheimer's
okay so Alzheimer's disease
is a condition where you lose cognitive
ability eventually it actually leads to
death right it happens later in life but
it's an important one because one
question is well how do we know what is
the cause of this disease what actually
makes this disease so dangerous and how
does it develop so here was it we have
an example of a simple project
where we took a data set from the public
domain related to Alzheimer's disease
and we want to compare people that do
have the disease and people that don't
have the disease and if we want to
compare those two groups we can do
what's called differential gene
expression analysis so we're looking at
the difference of genes that are
Amplified in healthy and down regulated
in Alzheimer's disease or the way the
other way around Amplified in
Alzheimer's disease and down regulated
in healthy condition so to do that we
will use a job called dec2 This is an
algorithm
that essentially looks at consistency
across each group and if the consistency
is significant so it is Amplified across
all samples within that group and
compared to the other group all of the
samples are down regulated then it
produces a p-value which is an
indication of this not being random but
something that is statistically
significant and gives us a value by how
much what's called a full change so how
much more is it Amplified in one
condition versus the other
now when we find those genes it is very
useful to know that these genes exist
but it's not very useful if we want to
understand what do they actually do and
to know what they do we perform what's
called enrichment analysis enrichment
analysis basically looks at sets of
genes so groups of genes and combines
them according to their Gene ontology or
according to a pathway a biological
pathway that they are involved in so
we're going to perform this step and we
can also add on to that analysis by
doing what's called genes set enrichment
analysis so two methods that kind of
work together and click on end okay so
what you should get is something that
looks like what you see on the screen
and this helps you remember what these
steps are you can see that they are
color coded we start with a comparative
analysis dc2 and then we perform
annotation and this is enrichment
analysis engine
analysis so what do we get as a result
of this
we can see a few different outputs so
first of all here you can have files you
can download these files onto your
computer or you can explore these
visually so you can explore them in a
dashboard you can view a volcano plot or
you can see here a heat map of top
differentially expressed genes
what is a volcano plot how many of you
are already familiar with what a volcano
plot shows
okay
okay
so
anyone else does anyone I'm sure okay
okay so if you're not familiar with this
this is okay great so so some people are
familiar with this already right what is
a volcano plot for those who are new to
this a volcano plot basically represents
each dot here represents a gene right so
the genes are dots
and they are positioned on this plot in
this two-dimensional plane right you can
see here the log to fold change and
right here the p-value so you can
basically think about this the higher it
is going up the more statistically
significant and into each side it is
going to be more significantly expressed
so upregulated
and there's two groups right so there's
a disease group and a healthy group
so if I compare disease to healthy I
will get some genes that are upregulated
in disease or some genes that are
upregulated and healthy right so that's
how you read this plot so I have a group
of genes the red ones are statistically
significant upregulated for the disease
and these are statistically significant
upregulated for healthy so that that
kind of helps me organize all of my data
together now this is an interactive plot
so if I hover over I will actually see
what this Gene name is you can see that
this is Gene called ATP binding cassette
subfamily c number 12. and so this is a
way to kind of bring in that annotation
and understand what's going on with this
volcano plot now let's take a look at
another plot this is what's called a
heat map
so this heat map also shows us if we
look on the bottom you can see that
these are annotation of those genes of
those samples sorry so the samples are
Alzheimer's disease so the disease
samples are right here and right here we
have old so these are just healthy old
individuals
and you can see that some genes right
are upregulated so here Ram fill in 3A
is down regulated in Alzheimer's disease
and upregulated in disease
now the dashboard organizes all of this
information together and gives us some
control over how it is presented so we
can actually change some of this
visualization over here for example I
can change the level of significance if
I'm interested to kind of filter out
some of those points and I get right
away the number of those genes at the
bottom
over here I have the Heap map and I can
select 20 top or maybe 50 top genes
right or maybe you can limit it to 10.
which will make it easier for me to see
what's going on
I can also change the way this looks and
maybe save this for my
um for my presentation or publication or
something like this right down below I
can also explore individual genes so
right here
let's look for a gene called vgf
okay and I can see that these two genes
look the same so they are down regulated
in Alzheimer's upregulated and healthy
right so this allows me to navigate some
of that information in an interactive
way I can also look at the enrichment
plots right so the enrichment plots as I
mentioned organize this information
according to Gene ontology terms so
biological processes are listed here and
the size correlates with how many genes
are actually involved in this process
and right here I also have keg Pathways
so those pathways are listed right here
and again the same way I can now see
that there are two main Gene ontology
processes and one main pathway so the
pathway is
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis right
makes sense related to brain function
cognitive function Etc so
if I want to now perform in-depth
download in-depth Downstream analysis I
can also download all of this data by
clicking on export downloading the
different types of data that I have
right here right so again what did we do
we understood how the logic of
differential gene expression analysis
helps us make biological interpretation
of data if we understand the context the
project where this data came from okay
how do we understand the context well
after you have completed the basic
coursework you can now explore different
projects that we have on here and the
projects are data sets taken from the
public domain that are curated
and organized in such a way that you can
perform these exploratory analyzes on
your own understanding what's going on
and you can find projects on a variety
of topics like
cancer Neuroscience uh infectious
diseases
Agriculture and even space onyx
so
another part right so we talked about
playing around with data right you have
all of these different uh examples that
you can kind of look at and and play
with another process is to learn how to
code right so a lot of these methods
that we just looked at
so we looked at for example how to
create a heat map or we looked at how to
create a volcano plot or we looked at
how to perform enrichment analysis right
all of this is done with commonly used
tools in bioinformatics that are called
packages and these packages are
typically used to produce figures to
produce standardized results
Etc
so the way that you can start learning
how to use these packages is by looking
at some coding exercises that we have
uh for example here we have a course
called introduction to data science in r
and let's take a look at one common
um problem that people have which is
loading data and visualizing it okay why
is this such a problem well most
tutorials online if you want to learn
how to code in R we'll start with let's
write hello world or something like that
right but here we are performing some
fairly complex analyzes on you know very
specific types of data and we would like
to know how to do that how to do
something relevant to what we already
understand and are interested in
okay
um so to do that
um we are going to see an example
so in this example uh we are loading
some data and we can run all of this
right within the browser right so right
here I'm going to click on run and it
gives me an error and that is because
the objective of this practice is to fix
the syntax of the code okay so right
here I need to include table
and again I have an heir and that's
because you see the syntax is incomplete
and I have an answer but it is incorrect
so if I follow all of the directions
right and I actually look at what this
says I can start learning
okay
like this
okay the answer is still incorrect so I
need to read the directions here but the
idea is that I go from understanding how
something is being used right so how
something is leading to a biological
insight
and once I understand that once the
concept is clear to me and I want to
obtain the technical skills to do it I
can go back and learn how do people
actually use this kind of coding to
produce more and more complex
visualization analysis interpretation
etc for example here we are learning how
to make a scatter plot box plot
histogram and heat map right what we
just saw being used right here in our
ability to analyze these differentially
expressed genes
so
both sides are important right and
what's important
um to do with this is to uh now organize
the process right so all of you are now
getting started right you're getting
started with something that is fairly
simple
um and you are going to now continue to
build on that Foundation by exploring
different types of projects by learning
how to practically run these kinds of
pipelines and and write code and
eventually what do you do with this
right so let's say you've got a couple
of certificates let's say you've even
learned something useful right and
you've understood something what to do
next well in my personal experience I've
realized that just having a certificate
is not really that transformational
so for example this is me a few years
ago my son was still small and I had a
certificate from the Harvard Business
School
um you know and that certificate over
the years I've obtained many different
certificates for different types of
coursework that I had completed and
those certificates have proliferated so
much we now have Coursera edx udemy
Etc right so many different certificates
what is really the value well what we
discovered is that when you go to a
potential collaborator or if you're
looking for a job leveraging the skills
that you have it is more important to
have a portfolio to say I have created
this project I've analyzed this data I
have understood this subject and I know
how to do it right to show that it's not
enough just to have a certificate it is
much better to start building up up your
portfolio so so to help you build up
that portfolio we have these project
um specialization tracks
in oncology in infectious diseases in
neuroscience and in agriculture and in
each one of those specialization tracks
again there are things to understand
right so things that you need to
understand in the context in the data in
the types of analyzes but then you
become more independent and you can
start asking your own questions so to
help you build out a portfolio we have a
special program called a research
fellowship or you can do this even on
your own and the way to do that is to
reach 10 000 points
to complete a number of courses that you
know we have on how to design a
bioinformatics project and after you
have done that you can actually submit a
project proposal that our team will
review and help you with and then
publish that project and make that
project available under your profile
so let's take a look at some of those uh
projects that others have done
um already
so again these are practical courses if
we want to go and find a project you
simply click right here on project and
you will see many interesting project
examples that you can start with
or if you would like to start working on
your own independent project in your tab
in your profile you go to the projects
tab
you can see these are some project
drafts that I'm working on
and right here you can start a new
project right so this is only going to
be available once you reach a certain
level
for example you can see that I have 33
000 points right so it's over 10 000
points and I have completed all of the
requirements and I can now start a new
project if you want to see other
people's project what have others worked
on you can click right here on projects
and see all of the projects that our
research fellows have been working on
right so let's say I am a student and I
would like to develop a portfolio of my
own to share with a potential
collaborator to share with a potential
employer or to even know for myself that
I have done something with the skills
that I have obtained right I have
learned about bioinformatics but now I
have done something with it and it could
actually be a very good first step
towards a publication so here we have
many such people that have completed
projects either independently or with a
team
always Guided by a mentor that can
provide feedback on the progress of that
project and eventually actually some of
these people went on to publish
so you can see
a lot of these individuals again you can
click on this project you know kind of
understand what it's about and you can
also see the person's profile right and
when you see the person's profile you
can connect with them on LinkedIn and
see so this project that she has
completed is also now a publication so
you can see that she has a preprint and
she also has a publication right so that
is really I think the ultimate goal of
this process not only have you learned
about bioinformatics you've understood
the specific applications of
bioinformatics in a particular domain
but you have also then shown that you
can leverage what you have learned to
design an independent project
so Onyx logic is a community
where we learned together work together
and develop a portfolio but what's next
what can you do with all of these
achievements what can you do with all of
these accomplishments
so please write a comment if you can in
the chat what is your goal right let's
think a little bit about where do you
want to go with all of this
you might be wanting to go into research
right so for example you're a graduate
student you would like to join a lab you
would like to pursue some specific
project that you maybe already know what
it is or just exploring and looking for
an interesting project that somebody
else is working on
how do you go to a faculty member or a
researcher or professor and tell them I
want to be involved in your project and
why should they take you right well
looking from The Faculty side from the
researchers side typically they are
looking for people who can bring real
value to the project right away right
the whole concept of somebody coming and
helping in a project is that they don't
just learn about what you're doing but
they contribute and they make progress
within the field that you're in
and so you're looking for people that
have a demonstrated background of doing
something useful that's number one and
number two that they already understand
what you are doing right you don't want
to spend hours and hours and hours to
explain what it is that you're working
on you want someone that has already
done the literature review that already
understands what are the unanswered
questions that maybe even has tried to
attempt to answer those unanswered
questions so
I would come to a researcher like that
and I would show them that I have done a
project or maybe several in the field
that I am interested in that I have read
the latest literature that I have found
the data sets that are available online
and I have explored those data sets and
now I've become a top candidate for that
person to hire me because I know and
they know that we've done the work
let's say I am looking for an industry
career right if I'm looking for an
industry career what do I do with all of
these skills that I have well the first
thing that I got to do is I have to
figure out what kinds of jobs are out
there for people like me
so here we have a listing of jobs
on the portal
where you can start understanding what
types of jobs are available and what are
they looking for in terms of experience
skills and background
so here you have academic jobs
academic jobs are related to research
maybe some of them are junior like a
research associate or senior like
director of biotechnology
their internships in bioinformatics
so let's say you have zero skills right
you're just getting started but you
would like to understand what it looks
like uh in terms of a real professional
environment so here you have uh jobs in
the US
in India
um and other places as well
experience building so experience
building is when you already have maybe
significant amount of skills but you
would like to build upon that and have
more information you know about where
this direction could develop for you so
this is an experienced building as well
so here you can search by country you
can search by category and ultimately in
each one of these jobs you will be able
to find what exactly are they looking
for so for example sometimes they will
say You must have a PhD
sometimes they will say you only need a
bachelor's degree and you only need to
have like a year of experience
so
let's look at
how all of this ties together
so I'm going to skip the details we have
a lot of information on the different
programs that are available but let's
look at how all of this fits together so
let me actually go to my first slide and
let's summarize what we have learned
today and by the way if you have any
questions or comments feel free to add
those in the chat
so first of all we talked about the role
of data in research life cycle how
there's continuing uh you know amounts
of data being generated across many
different domains and there's really a
gap and that Gap cannot be solved by a
highly specialized group of people it
needs to be the job of everyone so
literacy in data analysis and
interpretation is the domain of everyone
who is participating in biotechnology
Agriculture and Medicine
number two you can choose to become an
expert but even if you don't become an
expert you at least need to understand
the logic of what's going on and that's
where it's important for everyone to
understand how data is generated
conceptually how it is analyzed and how
to interpret it and sometimes that means
you can develop a lot of data science
skills but at least you should know how
to manage and analyze this data by
looking at examples and understanding
each step along the way
then we talked about how to get started
and we talked about that it's often
times for people like us who already
have a lot of experience who have
invested a lot of years or months into
studying this particular domain it is
important for us to you know not go back
to the basics and write hello world on
the computer that's irrelevant what is
relevant is starting to deal with real
data sets and making real analyzes that
are meaningful and so omixlogic provides
you with a clear and fast path to get
there in a meaningful way
then we talked about careers how to get
there and what kinds of careers are out
there so we talked about whether it's
enough to just have a certificate and
say I know I've read I've listened to
someone tell me about this or is it more
important for actually doing and
demonstrating what you have done by
developing a portfolio of projects
and then finally we discussed the
community right and so my question to
you today is what do you think when we
uh we want to you know do to grow this
community so this community today has
over 10 000 participants around the
world when we have participants in India
in China in Australia in uh Africa in
the US in South America in Canada in
Israel in Saudi Arabia right we have
participants from all over the world
now just having those people is is one
step but the next step is building out
this community so the community doesn't
just you know appear on its own the
community is somewhere where you benefit
by taking something and you provide
value by giving something so first of
all how can you take
we have offered many resources that you
can start using for free and eventually
pay an affordable rate of just ten
dollars a month to go all the way
we then provide affordable mentor-guided
programs that you can leverage to build
out your portfolio experience and
develop a project so that is how you can
take how can you give well there are
several different ways to give first of
all you can give by becoming a mentor so
ultimately after you have completed the
training and have developed an
independent project you yourself can
help others go through the same paths
you can become a mentor to a group of
students or work with our regional
coordinators in Africa in India in the
US to help others as well
you can also contribute project examples
right so we have a few but we would love
to grow that and you can get paid for
that so if you are
um an expert in the field you understand
some topic like agriculture or
infectious diseases or oncology we would
like to talk to you about some project
idea that you have that could be
developed into a Learning Resource for
others to use
and finally you can also become an
ambassador if you think that this is an
important domain and field
and you know of other students or
researchers who need to learn
bioinformatics and apply bioinformatics
to their research we would like you to
be an ambassador for us at your
University in your city in your country
whatever it might be so our team is here
and if you would like to connect with us
and discuss this further we would love
to talk to you about that as well
so I will share my email
if you would like to connect with me
directly I already shared my profile on
omnics logic and uh you've connected
with me on LinkedIn if you would like to
contact me email is probably one of the
best ways and easiest way to do that but
also our team is here and you probably
know adekunle Daniel and fe uh sonalika
or just be and others who are here so
feel free to contact them as well
so with that I will finish up my part of
this presentation and uh turn it over
back to
um whoever is going to finish up and
maybe add on to what I just mentioned
hello
Daniel
all right thank you everyone
um appreciate all the feedback and
comments and again looking forward to
connecting with you
um I will definitely share with you
um the slides through our team
um and and thank you again for joining
today
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]